[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tour de temps
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
m
[Applaudissements]
car elle est d'accord avec les
mitrokhine je vois qu'on vous enlevez
votre mémoire soit féroce tâche sera
d'accord je tiens bien c'était mission
il y aura des vrais maquillage coiffure
add vraiment se transforme et ils vont
vraiment ce sera dans leur tessiture
quand ils chanteront quand même mais
mais là mais moi je vous ai trouvé très
bien vraiment l'annoncé sera ce sera ce
sera quand même de très très haute
qualité à baisser sur un programme très
drôle on dirait mesrine
ouais vous dites vous dit pas joué le
jeu et vous voyez autour de cette table
ouais pas mal de fautes chute était là
ouais à la peut-être pas laisser fédéral
animé tout ça et bien vous savez quoi là
où d'ailleurs prouvé non down alors
alors
s'il vous plaît laissez moi parler c'est
moi laissez moi parler je vais redire
exactement ce qui a été dit autour de
cette table par certaines personnes je
crois qu'ils avaient jugé thierry et moi
je crois que la veille n'aura au lieu de
les arrêter ils ont dit karine n'a pas
l'habitude de présenter des pride de
divertissement de plateau voilà elle va
vous répondre car il qu'est ce que vous
pensez qu est ce que vous répondez à ça
attendez vous n'avez pris trop tard il
n'y a pas de micros il est tombé à
l'essai prenait le micro m'apprenait
micro macro et micro moque je vais vous
le ferez débranché à minuit je voulais
dire à ma coiffeuse même tu es allé je
voulais dire que quand on a présenté
trois ans les molières avec un public